je mets guy bedos avons parlé mais c'est
de pompidou dans votre livre
who's les rangs le oui l'a même pas là à
la fin j'ai rencontré une fois chez chez
des amis sur beaucoup arrivent en tout
cas et je rencontre des tas de gens
j'avais trouvé très amusant c'est plutôt
le respect humoristes de pompidou qui
m'avait frappé je ne sais pas pourquoi
vous aimez il est intervenu à raconter
ce que vous racontez votre lit oui oui
celle que tu intéressant surtout en face
me sur haguenau qui est allé vision
chirac nous avait d'ailleurs joué un
rôle à l'époque non mon affaire si on
fait dire ça me paraît un peu dérisoire
d'en parler mais si mais si mais si je
vous engage une affaire de saltimbanques
enfin les saltimbanques ont quelquefois
maille à partir avec la politique
oui c'est vrai que dans mon livre je jeu
[ __ ] ostroff monsieur contamine qui est
maintenant directeur président je n'ai
pas de troisième chaîne qui était à
l'époque
le directeur de la télévision l'ouver tf
et sophie daumier mois nous avions nous
avions fait une émission de variétés
bien innocente un peu turbulent
peut-être enfin que dans le temps de cet
atelier qui fait mais voilà taquine et
et missions ont été réalisées par
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de talent
marcel bluwal qui dont les sympathies
pour le parti communiste était connue
n'était pas encore inscrit au parti
communiste et puis nous avons connu là à
cause d'eux lui valent sans doute à
cause de moi un peu parce que bon bah je
t'ai 165 c'était avant 68
j'étais peut-être un peu gauche
justement l'heure c'est-à-dire
révérencieux insolent un peu dérangeant
parmi texte par la façon dont je parle
des choses les gens ont été
littéralement censuré c'est à dire que
je ne sais pas si vous avez lu un livre
d'irwin show qui s'appelle on de
troubles qui se situe en amérique sous
le mccarthysme j'ai eu le sentiment de
connaître ça à la télévision française à
l'époque je sais que ça peut arriver
encore maintenant ce n'est pas là ce
soir alors que je suis en train de
m'exprimer à la télévision que je vais
jouer les égorger enfin vers on peut on
peut interdire des choses des gens et
des choses
maintenant on le fait d'une autre façon
les ont aidés conseils ou ont des
commandes au dernier moment ça fait
beaucoup aussi
d'après des commandes non non non
c'était inscrit dans tous les journaux
sont deux semaines j'aurais eu un
scandale et un papier dans le nouvel
observateur
ce qui est important c'est face et dans
le journal oui parce qu'on est sûr
voulait parvenir votre après la wii bon
ben la mission a été mise aux oubliettes
et j'avais avec ma femme j'avais été
voir beaucoup de gens et j'avais eu
affaire à des gens totalement totalement
chinois ne parlent pas de la chine
populaire mais dans le côté un peu
pénétrable de ça vous ne savez pas ce
qui se passait et je te mets une mission
très bonne moi je trouvais que c'était
injuste parce que je voyais je regardais
la télévision aussi je voyais celle des
autres et je me demandais pourquoi on
atteindrait celle là n'étaient pas plus
mauvaise que que certaines
et puis et puis bon je vous j'avais même
était déjà un peu fou j'avais conçu le
projet de d'enlever les missions de la
kidnapper
il l'a projeté aux journalistes de la
presse spécialisée pour leur montrer
justement que et son mérite est passé
c'est important
c'était le début c'est important et on
n'était jamais reçu par monsieur
contamine sur haguenau vous avez reçu
mais à l'époque très très gentiment
c'est à peu près la seule personne que
j'ai rencontrée je le dis je lui rends
hommage prochaine fois j'invite
contamine oui j'ai ouï oui
alors oui mais voulait former la pompe
idoux longuet a balisé par les noms est
là puisque le local de joindre des dons
de pompidou depuis ce soir là on m'a
demandé de payer mon dîner sasp et nous
ne nous avaient pas pu venir voir mon
spectacle et puis peut-être que ça c'est
pas
on me dit vous pouvez pas été premier
ministre à l'époque et je je n'avais
aucune antipathie pour lui parce qu'il
avait la réputation d'être assez
libérale au vrai sens du mot pas comme
maintenant
il était vraiment je crois en coulisses
sans que ça se sache
et alors il est intervenu et non mais
c'est pas c'est simple c'est que ces cas
là il a fallu qu'on le demande et puis
et puis bon alors que c'est tellement
milliers aller voir ces gens là mais
qu'est ce qu'on a fait mais vous qu'est
ce qu'elle à cette émission mais pour sk
ne passe pas ça et puis et puis pompidou
envoyé une lettre à cet ami qui vous
avait présenté et qui lui avais je me
souviens demander d'intervenir en disant
c'est très triste de faire pleurer les
clowns citoyen peut enfin bon il avait
envoyé une lettre puis d'une autre une
amie se contamine une autre à cet
amusant jeu bon je suis intervenu
j'espère que cette cette intervention
aura quelques fois le lendemain tous ces
gens là sont téléphonés on a gagné ce
qui l'émission passe ceux qui peuplent
le directeur de chaîne n'étaient pas les
mêmes oui elle devrait revenir à malte
aminé est maintenant directeur de la
chaîne de la libre parole fr3 c'est le
claude mauriac
oui alors vous parlez de malraux